I could figure these first three out on my own without a calculator, just by
using the method we've been using. I rewrote each of the numbers we wanted to
take the log base 10 of as 10 to some power. 1 is 10 to the 0, so that gave us
0. 10 is 10 to the 1, so taking its log in base 10 gives us 1. And log base 10
of 100 equals 2. However, I don't know how to write the number 2 or the number
20 or the number 200 as 10 to some power. So for these, I need to use my
calculator, let's try one of them out. How about the first one? So, log base 10
of 2 equals this long decimal. I'm going to round to the fifth decimal place.
Entering the last two problems on the calculator, gives me long decimals as
well. Log base 10 of 20 is 1.30103, about. And log base 10 of 200 is about
2.30103. Please remember, these are rounded answers.